el alcalde de Nueva York ha declarado el
estado de emergencia en la ciudad porque
aquí las autoridades se ven incapaces de
hacer frente a esa avalancha de miles de
inmigrantes que está llegando a la
ciudad de Nueva York a la gran manzana
procedentes de Arizona y Texas dice el
alcalde ericadams que desde abril han
llegado cerca de 17.000 inmigrantes y
que ya no hay sitio para ellos los
refugios están saturados y no saben
dónde hospedarlos dice que se han creado
cerca de 42 nuevos refugios de
emergencia y cerca de 5.000 niños de
estos inmigrantes han sido escolarizados
en los últimos meses pero ya no hay nada
más que hacer porque no hay medios para
eso por eso se ha declarado el estado de
emergencia esto le permite a la ciudad
contar con los fondos del estado y del
Gobierno Federal y dice el alcalde
ericadas que en esa ayuda se necesita
ahora mismo porque está previsto
invertir mil millones de dólares en
ayudar a estos inmigrantes En qué se van
a invertir pues se han creado ya unas
carpas para alojar a estos inmigrantes
que están llegando cerca de la isla de
Manhattan se están haciendo también
acuerdos con compañías de crucero para
que los propios barcos alojen a los
inmigrantes Incluso se está hablando con
otros estados para desviar a esos
inmigrantes a otros estados pero al
final el problema Sigue estando a
vigente el único lo único motivo aquí es
que se está trasladando de estado por
eso el alcalde de la ciudad pide ayuda
para poder dar trabajo para poder dar
escuelas y para poder dar pues comida y
alojamiento a todos estos inmigrantes
que están llegando procedentes de
América Latina que llegan Arizona y
Texas y Desde allí como sabéis son
enviados por los gobernadores en
autobuses hasta ciudades demócratas como
Washington o Nueva York